hello everyone and welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does
physics everybody else does math
descriptions and what do we do well we
do
explanations in physics
just wondered if i was still online had
problems lately with communication
transmissions anyways i'm going to
divide today
the show in three parts first part we're
going to be doing
extinction lots of issues
raised by people with respect to
extinction i guess
people are concerned maybe that's one
issue the other one is uh
obviously a lot of people are more into
politics than into science
and extinction in a lot of these
people's minds
has to do with uh political questions
questions about opinions of how the
world should be run and whether the
politicians are crooks and
that sort of thing and then the second
part i'm gonna
be doing um going to be
covering this physics issue uh known as
the quantum uh measurement problem
okay what problems do we have with
measurements
and finally i'm going to address
questions that people asked since last
time
okay so let's get started on extinction
a person says here says that
i am an animal he accuses me of being an
animal
yeah i'm an animal especially in bed you
know
uh yeah i'm an animal and very proud of
it
okay and uh you should be too because we
are all
animals and the way we do it in science
is we have to define
what an animal is and then you either
fit the category or you don't
it's just as simple as that so let's
find out what an animal
is okay this is the official version
okay
out there and it says that you know we
have rocks and
minerals those are not animals those are
not living entities
okay and then uh you have viruses
proteins and you know other um
you could say inert matter
uh they're just molecules you know a
virus is not a living entity
a lot of people think they are because
they say well they move around they get
a sick and so on so it's got to be
something that is alive
and that's not true virus is just a very
complex molecule just like a protein is
a molecule just like dna is a molecule
and the virus only works
its magic when it gets inside a cell
and that's where it starts you could say
moving okay what it does it's
uh makes copies it's a molecule that
makes copies of itself essentially
uh same with dna by the way uh other
than that well you have
what we know as living entities and you
know you can fit yourself in
any of these categories that you wish to
to fit in
if you're not an animal you be you are
insulted by
by someone saying that you're an animal
well uh you can be a tree or a flower is
that what you are
are you a plant are you uh fun fungi
uh algae bacteria archaea
you know i mean what are you uh you know
if you don't fit any of these categories
perhaps just perhaps
um you know you're you're an uh
martian okay uh
[Music]
you're kind of green uh maybe some kind
of mixture between uh
something that's alive and not uh
maybe between plant and animal so yeah
we have to define what an animal
is and the way we define it is uh there
you see
some of the things that an animal does
and that's how
typically people define these words
and it says multicellular eukaryotic
organisms that consume organic material
breathe oxygen
are able to move can reproduce sexually
and grow
okay eukaryotes they're organisms whose
cells have
nucleus enclosed within nuclear envelope
and prokaryotes are
unicellular organisms that lack a
nuclear membrane
or enclosed nucleus okay
essentially what it comes down to is
that um
i hope i'm still on i get an error from
uh
youtube so if someone could confirm that
i'm still
alive here uh youtube again is telling
me that i get an error i don't know
where i'm receiving these lately
but if you can hear me fine we'll
continue
anyways uh let me continue anyways and
so let me put this up there
here it is and this these are the
differences
between a uh prokaryote and a eukaryote
and then at the bottom you see the
differences between plant cells and
animal cells
okay and that's what distinguishes us
from plants and other
uh okay thank you i hope you can hear me
fine
um i hope you can read all this and
listen to me hear me fine okay anyways
these are the differences between
prokaryotes and
eukaryotes plant cells and animal cells
and you know you either fit on one side
or on the other
and if you don't like these definitions
well you know what you can do
is uh define the word scientifically
that way we know what you're talking
about when you get
uh yeah when you get uh excited when
someone tells you that you're an animal
what would you like to be called a plant
a rock
a mineral okay
uh you know what should we call you what
category should we put you if not in the
animal category okay and again we're not
talking about
um everyday language we're not talking
about
out there you know the
ordinary speech we're talking about
scientific language
this this site deals with science so we
need to define these terms so that we
can use them consistently and there you
have it
you know at least we should be able to
distinguish between a plant
and an animal and or i don't know a rock
okay we should be able to establish a
difference
okay okay along the same lines a fellow
says
or ass says uh it can be assumed that
higher terrestrial life developed
higher terrestrial life um
i don't know how high or how low uh
terrestrial life is
you know these are opinions what is high
what is low
uh is high an eagle is that what's high
and low as a fish
because he's in the water i mean i don't
know what high and low mean
okay uh so you got to clarify that but
i'm concerned about another word
and which is the one that concerns
biology
and there's not a single biology on
earth that's
ever learned to define the word by uh
life
and it turns out biology is the
study of life or so they say okay
hopefully it's not hopefully biology is
some kind of explanation and not just
the study
of okay but here it is uh here's a
definition for life okay so that we can
use it consistently
and we go with a word living or alive
what is a living entity okay
and it's a natural object that self
propels against the path
of least resistance primarily against
gravity
okay so if if you can um if you can move
towards against gravity okay uh
then you are a living entity and if
self-propelled
obviously by yourself okay of your own
volition
uh and there you see the unit of life
it's the cell
okay a couple examples one is a single
cell the other one is a cell moving
through
uh other cells i guess okay so this is
what
life is and what you got to do is define
life and
uh whether these are higher or lower
uh that's uh that's an opinion that's uh
i'm not sure how you can categorize that
uh we typically look at bacteria
and uh i don't know cells single cells
as uh something that is so basic i guess
we call
lower uh forms of life okay
uh but those are again more important is
that you find the word life so that you
can use a consistency
in the discipline known as biology
okay another issue uh raises
and he says following yeah
down syndrome people have healthy
children usually on nutrient dense
diets this is reversing the degeneration
this individual believes like many out
there that
food somehow changes uh
your genetic degeneration maybe
from one uh generation to another
you know and uh so there are people who
believe that by eating
uh they can reverse things like genetics
your genome or whatever you know uh
i don't think so okay your friend could
have
he's referring to a friend that i
mentioned the other day that has
she was missing one chromosome instead
of 23 she had 22
because of that her muscles
deteriorated and she the last time i saw
her which was some years ago
she could barely stand up she could
barely move her arm she was getting very
weak
because of her something affecting her
muscles
and she inherited that from her father
so this file says your friend could have
healthy
children if she was careful to consume a
nutrient-dense
diet with uh conception uh
i don't know maybe could be you know
some
sick people do have
normal children i know in fact of one
case specifically a high school
gal she had all kinds of problems
when she was young in fact to this day
but she had very healthy children maybe
what she had was not
genetic okay so the issue is genetics
here whether you can reverse
uh some kind of genetic process or some
genetic
constitution that you have some serious
problem that you might have
if you can reverse that by eating by
just
changing your diet and i'm not sure
that's the case
i'll give you an example you know
lions eat meat cows eat grass
and both of them you know because of
their different genetics
they produce meat under bones
you couldn't tell the difference uh much
i mean there
are obviously differences but uh you
know they're both mammals
one is a herbivore the other one's a
carnivore
and yet they certain such widely
different
foods and they both put meat on their
bones and they both have bones by the
way
and they they're constructed you know
also with a head for
legs etc so i'm not sure you can uh
say well i'm gonna eat asparagus or
whatever you know
and i'm gonna have my kid is instead of
four legs he's gonna have three legs
i don't think it's gonna work
uh he'll come out with four legs believe
me
okay uh now the fellow
lots of people ask questions regarding
politics and
this fellow came along those lines he
says war has nothing to do with the
economy
when the economy goes south from their
manipulation
war is all about politics and corruption
in government
people are so much into politics
and you know they should quit politics
they should get out of politics
completely you know
what can i say see if i got something
here now
to show you but uh what i'm saying is
that you know
you should you should get away from
politics politics is
no country in the world is different
they're all the same they all have
a mafia that runs the country
some call themselves communists other
call themselves capitalists
free markets mixed economies they have
all these different categories
they're all mafias they have a mafia on
top
that rules the country and they have
their
influences and they
put those influences you know in motion
they they do something with those
influences those ability to influence
uh the the country and so because they
can do that
uh they manipulate the country any way
they want
and it doesn't matter if you say well
i'm going to vote him out of office next
time around
i'll get someone else and the next guy
that you get
does the same thing and over and over
and over
since uh we've ever k at least since
we've
invented civilization so nothing has
changed
and no i say war has to do ultimately
with economics
what is economics management of
resources there you see a fellow even
said that
that's what economics is it's management
or resources
and when someone stands in the way of
your resources
what you do is you fight them you know
lion has to fight another lion
because he's in the way of his resources
primary one is food
but you know but he would like to have
the harem
okay the pride so that the gals can go
out there hunt something and he gets to
eat and he
in turn he protects them i give you a
protection
and so the guy standing in the way is
the other lion
so they got to resolve the situation and
usually it's not peaceful
okay so now war is about resources
ultimately not about uh corruption and
all that all governments are corrupt
there's no difference between them okay
i said why do you think they would
rather use bio weapons rather than
nukes because this uh bio weapons can be
focused on specific populations
and races killing off the locals and
leaving the infrastructure
intact well hopefully you're not talking
about
nukes because nukes obviously will
destroy buildings as well and you do
mention nukes
and you think if they start throwing the
nukes as well as the bio weapons
uh there's going to be anything left
in the cities especially if they drop
them on the cities
with a skyscraper still be there you
know i mean
i i think it's a done deal that when
they throw the uh
nukes at least that's it for man
and of course also if they uh
superimpose upon their bio weapons
okay so bioweapons are designed to leave
buildings and roads intact okay yeah
the bio weapons are designed to kill
people the nukes are designed to kill
people and buildings essentially that's
what he's saying okay
but uh i like his necessity statement he
says uh so yes
even more people will die this time
around meaning the third world war okay
in the billions yes but not everyone
well someone always survives a war right
and this time we're gonna serve fewer
will survive i guess
if there there is a nuke and bio war a
few will
survive that but let's say 10 000 people
[Music]
um
uh let's let's say uh uh ten thousand
people survive on earth
okay and you know they're not gonna
survive the ten thousand in the same
place they're gonna be scattered around
and one of the things that's gonna be
lacking is food because you've destroyed
everything
okay and so these people uh will be
there in their own little pockets
they won't know that there's someone
else on the other side because there
will
won't be any way to reach these other
people okay
and if you do you're in trouble because
you don't know if they're gonna
receive you or kill you you know uh
there's gonna be this
trust but verify issue right and so here
you are in your little pocket
what do you think is going to happen you
think are you
do you think you're going to reproduce
and have children start the adam and eve
things all over again no
first of all our genetic diversity is
gone we have little
very little genetic diversity meaning
that even if you reproduce
a couple generations later that's it
more than likely you're going to be
worried about some
subsistence farming you're going to be
producing food for yourself
and it's not going to give you much time
to
reproduce or would you want to produce
another individual
that is not going to do anything for you
except be
you know a just someone else that you
got to maintain
okay a dependent and then you have the
issue of what for
why would you produce another child do
you think you would have the
psychological uh
fortitude after a world war where
everyone's gone around you do you think
you would have the
fortitude to go in there and say okay
that's business as usual i'm just going
to have a kid
no those people who survive will just
live out their lives there won't be any
reproduction
and so even if you survive it's going to
be the end of man
one way or the other it's just gonna be
staggered it's not gonna be
all dying at the same time because of
nuclear war there's gonna be some
differences between the war when they
stop
throwing the uh nuclear weapons and
biological weapons
and whoever survives well he survives
until he dies and that's
it that's going to be the end of man so
we're talking about the extinction of
man one way or the other
so yeah everyone will die sooner
a little later but not not sooner but a
little later okay but they will all die
and uh so he says if economic is
management resources where do you
get war out of that again war has to do
with
managing resources and you would always
like to manage the resources of the guy
that's on the other side who's standing
in your way
you know lion has to fight another line
because this guy
the head of the pride he's standing in
the way of his progress of his
resources so yeah the war is about
resources ultimately
and you are destroying the collapse and
extinction of our current form of
government not humanity
no government the day government
collapses that's the end of humanity
okay there is no way to live without
government
okay and even if we live without
government the first thing we do is
create a government we create the rules
the laws
you know it's it's it's part of our uh
social culture uh that's what we are
we we are essentially we are social
animals
i'm sorry i said animals oh uh we are
social
animals and social animals need
a government okay uh
not that we want to have it but it's
like uh a government always
uh pops up it it comes out of nowhere
there is no such thing as a few humans
without a government
someone always rules or has
most of the influence okay
there's um another issue along the same
line
war people are concerned with war and i
think we should be concerned with war
because i think
we're headed that way probably very
likely that
if there is a clash uh you know
somewhere it could
turn into it could escalate right it
says is a world
where people only have one kid do you
think
uh they they will be as eager to send
them to into war
well uh the next war will not be with
people
okay it'll be pressing buttons again
we're talking about
nuclear and bio weapons uh it's gonna be
a
a button war you don't need people for
that you just need five fingers in each
hand and be especially the index finger
and just press buttons
okay so a lot of the war even
conventional war today is done like that
you know they send those missiles
from the ships all the way to where they
want them
so a lot of that is already being done
in one way or another okay another
common issue question someone raised uh
says
says markets have already been disrupted
the crisis is not in the market
it is in the government people are so
concerned with politics
try to maintain your mind on uh
science you know causes causes
primarily not opinions not
recommendations but causes
a physical cause efficiency in this case
we're not talking really about
we could talk about causes when we talk
about war for example
or markets collapsing but uh the issue
is also
a philosophical issue we want to know
the reasons
and the purposes people had for for
investing
for uh you know that sort of thing you
have to have an explanation
then you're doing science otherwise
you're doing just uh philosophy and
religion which is opinion which is
recommendation which is how
government should be run and you don't
like that other government and so
you know that's that's all opinion
that's religion
and then he says there is a cycle the
food
i have no idea what that means uh you
would need to clarify that
uh in quite a bit of detail for me to
even address it
okay next issue file says money is the
most saleable
good usually gold so it's not a concept
the word money is a concept okay
money is a concept uh now there are
different diverse
diverse forms of money you have gold
which is tangible
meaning the rock the coin whatever you
have in your hand
that's tangible and that's an object but
money the word money
is a concept and essentially it means
trade you're
exchanging goods or services or whatever
you're exchanging
money means exchange essentially okay
that's
that's that's what the word money
represents it's the medium of extinct or
the
currency we use to do exchange
but it's also could be a solid product
and one of the products is food money
food can be a money okay
uh the problem is we're not used to real
money like golden instead we're mostly
using counterfeit money
again opinion counterfeit means uh the
guy has a political opinion
a recommendation maybe don't don't get
that money
because it's counterfeit okay um
here's another question along the same
line
paul says yeah let me get this here
right money the good and highest demand
in a given economy
good luck ever having an economy without
a good
in highest demand well uh
the day that the global economy
collapses
okay then food will be the only
uh good in in the highest demand the
only demand
and uh that'll be the only resource you
will manage meaning
you will have an economy or management
resource
you'll be managing food and you will not
have money because
money will be no more you will no longer
trade
okay you will no longer trade like we
never trade in i don't know
the paleolithic there was no trade
okay we invented trade when we invented
after the neolithic when we invented
commercial farming we went from
subsistence farming where you produced
for yourself your family your clan
whatever
and at some point people started
exchanging things
because they were able to primarily have
trust without trust there could
never have been
exchange money uh trade
you have to have uh confidence you have
to have faith
and that does not that did not exist in
the paleolithic
even among humans the cro-magnons of
kermagne
there was no trade between them it was
like the lions
a guy who was from a different clan he
was your enemy he was a different
country
let alone if he's a different species
like neanderthals
you have people out there
paleontologists who say that
the neanderthals and the crow magnets
are traded
seashells i guess for prostitution
i don't know maybe to sleep with a
beautiful
neanderthal gal harry
well you gotta take your clothes off she
doesn't
okay uh another
issue uh father can you elaborate
on why you consider
service jobs to be the same as being
unemployed
okay so let me address that issue i've
addressed it more or less
in the past i'm going to give you a
little clue there of why i consider this
you know it's it's not it's not
part of our um
what was the say it's not part of our uh
uh
material world okay it's part of a world
in which uh we have all these services
these
abstractions and so i distinguish
abstractions from
uh solid things from objects okay so
that's the first
difference we have there but here let me
give you the analogy
okay for a little story okay here it
goes
and the way it works is this is god and
he's looking down
on the world okay and uh
he's um he's what does he see
what is it that he sees well he sees the
things that we constructed
he sees the buildings he sees the land
for sure he sees what we
were the crops that we planted or
or uh are about to be harvested
he sees uh cars he sees ships he sees
i don't know everything we built bridges
roads
that he sees he doesn't see
insurance what is insurance
insurance is a promise so those people
who work in insurance they say well i
got a job i'm working in
insurance well yeah according to our
organization we call it a job
but the guy's not producing anything any
more than the guy who uh sings
what is he producing well you can go
over
all these issues like saying well he
produces value and
he produces something that someone wants
to hear and is willing to pay for and
all that stuff
he's producing nothing when you produce
an intangible you're producing
absolutely
nothing okay god only sees
good old god even the universe right so
he should know
he sees only what's constructed what's
there
and so that's the difference between
like i said the other day and i'm going
to get to that in a second
wealthy and rich okay more or less well
he's a guy who has something
has tangible things and so how wealthy
is the earth
well just look at what you have what's
out there
you know the countries are always judged
whether they're advanced nations or
backward nations
how did they judge that how do they come
up with all these uh
notions well they look at how developed
the country is i mean how many roads
does it have
what does it have you're looking down
through the solid satellite
or through god's eyes and what do you
see down there
well if you don't see much construction
you see just farmland and uh
you know services okay
there's nothing there oh
what you're gonna look at is what what's
constructed with
what is tangible what has that's what
really has
value the promise of um
of uh for example insurance
that's nothing and you say well yeah i'm
gonna collect when i get sick
uh someone pays for my doctor and they
give me services
they cure me they operate on me you know
the day
the world the global economy collapses
let's just assume that the only thing of
value will be
what god can see on you know all those
promises like insurance
they're not there anymore they vanished
into thin air the singing
that went away uh you know all these
things that people
did all the verbs they disappear
the only thing that remains are the
nouns and that's how you can tell the
difference between
you know what is and what ain't what is
are the things what we constructed
what's already constructed what we built
and the food obviously these are the
tangibles the intangibles
i don't know uh gone with the wind
okay uh one file says
uh maybe a dead jubilee will be the
last ditch attempt yeah i think uh
this might actually happen that
maybe the last straw will be that
governments
will somehow deal with the debt
in such a way that it will be part of
the global collapse
of the global economic collapse so i
think one of the
process that will eventually happen
will be that there will be a jubilee
for debt you know and that might be one
of the last steps that
governments take because after that i'm
not sure what tools
both monetary or fiscal they can apply
to restart the global economy you know
what are they going to
do print more money uh devalue what's
already been
devalued to close to zero to having no
value because nobody wants the money
why because they can't reach the end of
the month with what little money they're
giving and so on
you know so yeah i think the debt
jubilee is uh
part of that process okay
okay uh here's the rich issue rich
versus wealthy okay
and phil says the rich guy has
purchasing power a wealthy person also
has purchasing power
right so there's no difference right a
poor person has less purchasing power
yeah
okay we understand that finally we
understand
the rich and the wealthy have nothing to
do with your extinction event
never said they did in fact let me put
the answers here to them
so you can see them side by side okay
okay here it is
what this fellow is saying you know he's
saying that uh
the risk worse is the wealthy uh all i'm
saying is that
rich i'm redefining what rich is and
what wealthy is
rich is a person who has liquidity has
money
but does not have things and wealthy is
a guy who has things but not
not does not have money does not have
liquidity to anything the trade of
uh that is liquid now like i said a rich
person can become wealthy by buying
things and wealthy can become rich by
selling things no problem at all
but i want to keep those two terms
separate rich from wealthy so that we
can use them consistently
in a uh dissertation okay that's that's
the point so we're not using the terms
of ordinary speech
we want to give them some scientific
meaning so that we distinguish
rich from wealthy and well
i was going to say here that let me put
this aside for a second uh
i put their blue bloods versus
dilapidated castles or
or having dilapidated castles uh you
know
here in germany you have people who are
blue bloods
and by that i mean you know they descend
from big names of the past
and so they inherited these names and
they inherited maybe a castle
so the guy you'd say oh man he's rich
turns out he's not rich in fact uh he's
more or less on social security
he depends on the government to help him
out with handouts either
through welfare or some form of
help coming out of taxes by the way
and you say how can that be possible the
guy's a blue blood he's got a castle
yeah the castle he might have a
dilapidated castle or a run-down castle
and it turns out that he's got no money
after centuries maybe his father maybe
he
himself they liquidated all their money
you know
played it at the casino or whatever and
lost all his money or maybe investing
and the guy has no money he's a blue
blood without money
he's wealthy but he's not rich
okay now he's got this castle but nobody
wants it
and it's got a little bit of history and
the guy
carries the name maybe he's a habsburg
you know
and he's got the castle and now what
does he do
nobody wants his castle he doesn't want
to really sell it because
he's tied to it culturally you know his
family
owned it for centuries what does a guy
like that do
that doesn't have any money to do
anything with that castle to even
you know prop it up and so what the
government does they give them money
they say look we'll give you money and
it's going to be good for germany
because we want you to fix this place up
you stay in there you're going to be the
tour guide
the habsburg tour guide by uh
by habsburg himself and you can tell
about your family's history
and we'll give you money we'll give you
a salary
and all we want you to do is fix up the
castle so that it's
good for tourism so the guy is really
wealthy but not rich and he can't sell
that castle partly because maybe nobody
wants it or a few people
there's not much of a market for it
another is that maybe the government
doesn't want uh
anyone to buy that because it's uh you
know
one of those things that the government
tries to keep
forever you know historical landmarks
etc
and so that's the arrangement they have
they give this guy welfare money
in order to keep the castle running so
yeah it's uh
not the same thing to talk about wealthy
and rich okay
that's the point i wanted to make there
and the next person
is uh the next issue is the rich and the
wealthy have nothing to do with your
extinction event
well i never said that they did okay so
i don't know where he got that i never
said that uh
the rich and poor have the rich and
wealthy have anything to do with
extinction i'm saying something else i'm
saying that
um you know i'm just distinguishing
between rich and wealthy so that we can
use these uh
words consistently in a dissertation
and then we have this uh issue uh that
he raises he says the haves and the
have-nots i brought
up that issue the other day uh saying
that in the future
when the world the world economy
collapses
there will be only two kinds of people
and some will be the haves the other
ones that have nots and the haves will
be those who have food
and have nots will be either those who
don't have food
for a short while and then they'll be
the dead
okay so um that's the way you got to
look at that
and so uh i don't do politics anymore to
talk about
marxism is for me you know
politics and it's just opinion okay
marxism is no different than
capitalism because uh all countries that
claim to be capitalist all countries
that claim to be
uh marxist uh what they do is
plain old half and half they do what is
called
a
mixed system okay some things are
capitalist
and some things are communist and you'll
see that in
every single country in the world there
is no country that is
purely capitalist or purity marxist
schooling is typically marxist
health in many countries is uh
what other things anything that is
social welfare you know
unemployment uh social security
all that stuff is kept as communism
marxism you could say it i mean that's
that's where it would fit
and then uh you go to china is it a
communist country no it's a capitalist
country
totally capitalist it's got a
dictatorship yes
but underneath you know it's all
capitalism everybody can
buy and sell and own land and all that
kind of stuff you know and
so it's capitalism there is no such
thing as
pure capitalism pure communism every
country in the world
is a mixed system is that the best way
to
govern well i don't know you know that's
an opinion not part of science
okay continuing here getting more into
the subject matter of extinction
person says the dinosaurs lived for
millions of years before the sun killed
them off
the sun killed them off well how did the
sun do that
i hope he's talking about the sun and
not a sun like my son you know
not like that okay he's talking about
the sun so what is the mechanism
how did it do it you got to tell me how
how the sun managed to kill us off
killed
the dinosaurs off what is the mechanism
so yeah i mean people
just say these things but they don't
have a mechanism there's a little sun
killed
did they fry them did the sun fry them
to death is that how
these animals died my god
okay and so here another person says
mainstream
blame climate change for dino extinction
uh not really okay i'll get to that in a
second
some vary on what caused this climate
change asteroids volcano co2 but i'm
sure they agree that it was the effect
of climate change
on food that killed off the dinos
i don't know here's the outline let me
give you an outline of what mainstream
believes
for the dinos okay here it is okay these
are the um
uh the steps first an asteroid hits the
earth
uh there is a climate change
but you gotta put it in the right
context okay because
uh there there's several aspects to that
one is the impact winter
okay uh which is the cloud covering the
earth
and so now you don't have any
photosynthesis
uh going on so the plants die okay
uh when the plants die well guess what
who follows next the herbivores right
and once they are no longer around guess
what the carnivores
are out okay so this is more or less the
sequence of events
the problem here is um that
impact winter cloud covering the earth
dust cloud etc
the question is how does that dis
produce selectivity how come
some animals die and others continue if
photosynthesis
is the same for the cactus as it is for
the
cycad cycad being the
ancient plant okay primarily you know
you have these cycads william sonia's
cycad likes as they were called some of
them uh
these plants these plants disappeared
and uh
magnolias you know all those continues
how does uh a dust cloud that affects
the entire planet
you know distinguish between one and the
other
and so unless you can answer that
selectivity that's what it's called
uh you have no theory and that theory
of the dust cloud doesn't explain
anything it doesn't explain
what what a next thing a mass extinction
theory should
explain which is selectivity
so i don't know how to get that notion
across the people people
say well it was this oh it was that yeah
but you got to explain the selectivity
issue if you can't explain what
what is what's the point of just stating
stuff
you know uh egg predation i mentioned
the other day
or someone mentioned gravity you know
okay fine
so you say egg predation how did that
work well you know they say they have
all these little mammals in the case of
dinosaurs right they came around they
started eating the eggs
of the mamma of the dinosaurs and they
could and so the new generation of
dinosaurs did not appear
well the first problem is uh you know
these little mammals
they were around for millions of years
why did it happen before
you know it's like saying that the
cockroaches are going to drive us out of
to extinction because they're going to
eat all our food in our fridge
or or kill our babies or something you
know
yeah please explain it how that's gonna
work out
you know you gotta explain how the how
these little animals
didn't uh uh do it before
and then you gotta explain okay so that
happened on land what happened in the
seas how did the reptiles
disappear did some the tiny animals eat
their eggs
in the seas and if so why didn't it
happen before
why did it happen 65 million years ago
more or less that's what you gotta
answer
okay so um what can we say uh these
theories
don't work out very well until you uh
can justify it
okay um person asks
are there signs of reduced size in
fossils in in
in the fossil record in a few final
generations
uh of the you know that conduced
to uh mass extinctions right human
beings are the fattest
we've ever been so i expect our great
starvation will start at least 50 years
from now
okay let's address the first question
says
is there a any evidence
for example in the case of the dinosaurs
for the fossil record where the final
red generations reduced in size
okay uh there is uh
uh one process uh known as
this island constriction where uh
some animals like elephants that got
stuck on an island or
also the mammoths that got stuck in an
island
and they start shrinking okay so there
is a process like that a million year
profit or
thousand hundreds of thousands of years
where these animals
actually shrink okay so there is a
process like that
but in general uh what we see in mass
extinctions
is the following here's a an example and
it's uh from the cretaceous
and here it is this is an ammonite okay
uh that was found
in germany and it dates to the end of
the cretaceous
and you can see that they're big it's uh
you know six feet tall six feet in
diameter
and so animals did grow big in those
days
towards the end of the extinctions
and not only i'm not only talking about
the cretaceous
i'm talking as well about you know for
example the
end of permian they were big animals end
of
triassic big animal end of the jurassic
we had the biggest animals on earth
before the whales came around
so you know always towards the end of a
mass extinction
the animals are big
that's the first clue the second clue is
they are old
they've been around for a while the
animals that die in a mass extinction
are always always always
old okay so keep that in mind it's the
old generation that
passes the baton to the new generation
that's what happens in a mass extinction
so those are the things that you got to
look at
and if you don't believe me well you go
out there and do your research and reach
your own conclusion
those are the assumptions under which i
work and you say well okay the ammonites
are were big
well yeah it turns out that the
mosasaurs which were monsters uh
sea reptiles they ate they fed on
ammonites
that was apparently their their biggest
lunch
[Laughter]
or dinner you know the element the the
food
that's what they wanted to eat that's
what they ate so what did these guys eat
well they again they were filter feeders
you know and so
these these folks ate this they ate four
amps
and uh and here you see the difference
between the four forearms
and the ones that came after you can see
the sizes the differences in sizes
the ones on the left which are the end
of the cretaceous end that disappeared
they were monsters for being plankton
they were they were huge they were the
dinosaurs of the seas
of the uh world of foreign miniferas
okay
and what do you see on the right well
those were the new ones and they started
all over again these are the ones that
we're going to radiate
during the tertiary which is essentially
you know
our world today so these uh
expanded and they obviously they
disappeared as well many of them
okay but yeah towards the end of a mass
extinction
the animals grow big we are an example
we were smaller in the past way in the
past
you know if we take it to homo habilis
or
even homo erectus uh you know we were
bigger
in general okay so keep that in mind uh
towards the end of an
a mass extinction animals grow big in
fact um
today among modern humans which you can
maybe date
to 200 000 years ago you're right uh 200
or 300
000 years ago we are the largest that
humans have ever been
so we are the t-rexes if we're going to
use that as a size
uh comparison we are the t-rexes of
the linear of our lineage we're the last
of our kind the last of the hominids
and of course we are big it doesn't get
any bigger than that we're not going to
grow much much bigger
but today we see like you know people in
holland are the i think the biggest uh
people the tallest people on earth as an
average
and man they are huge they are the
t-rexes of
humans of man okay
couple more issues here i think
uh yeah here it is uh yeah i just want
to say that
we do want to do extinction 101 before
we do 102
and uh some people try to
meet that standard okay we want to make
sure we understand a mass extinction
before we
extrapolate that to a human extinction
which is extension 102.
and i always leave you or i try to leave
you from now on
with this question which gives you a
clue
to why mass extinctions happened
that's what i'm gonna argue okay and
that is the homework is
why did the fauna in the seas disappear
at the same time as the animals
on land if you can figure that out if
you can figure
why that happened more or less
simultaneously
well i think you've figured out a very
important clue
of how mother nature does her
mass extinctions okay so let's move on
to the lecture today which is about
quantum measurement
here it is what is this quantum
measurement
problem we have a problem in measuring i
mean what do you do you take the
measuring tape you stretch it across the
table why would that be a problem
okay see it sounds like a
straightforward thingy right
okay and here it is okay it's uh the
quantum measurement problem
these are the essentially the main
points
how are weather wave function collapse
occurs
okay i like the fact that they say
weather
not just how because if you say weather
you mean
it could it maybe it doesn't occur or
what are we trying to answer here
okay if it doesn't occur then there's
nothing to answer
only if it if you have that how then yes
you would try to answer
how it happens you know what caused it
to happen
but if they say whether are they saying
that sometimes it doesn't happen
and we're going to get into what a
function
a wave function collapse means okay but
keep that in mind okay
that says the inability to observe such
a collapse directly
okay has given rise to different
interpretations of quantum mechanics
what are we saying here okay something
very important they're saying inability
to observe
okay i thought the mathematical physics
harped upon observation they say you
must observe
and here these people are saying that we
have no ability
to observe okay uh the
wave function collapse
so is this outside the bounds of science
is that what they're saying because we
have no way of testing the hypothesis as
they say
okay so keep that in mind as well and
then the other one the different
versions
of you know this these interpretations
right
post key sets of questions that each
physical
interpretation must answer and that's
what it comes down to
what these people have done is they've
come up with
all sorts of physical interpretations
for this unobservable this uh
by its very nature this unobservable
phenomena which they call the
uh measurement problem which means the
wave function collapse so they have no
way of seeing it they have no way of
testing it
all they can do is describe whether they
describe they describe what they can see
what they can take pictures of maybe
what they can
simulate with their computers but they
can't see the
mediators themselves and so they're
guessing
and no problem there they can
hypothesize
size as it's called they can theorize
they can say look
i've got an idea how that could happen
that's no problem
the problem here is the irrational
explanations you're going to hear
next of how these people have answered
this so-called wave function collapse
okay so here it goes
here's a well first let's get to the
measurement
what is a measurement i mean what are
they talking about when they say we have
a measurement problem
okay so what is a measurement well here
it is okay
and it sounds pretty much like uh the
story of the emperor's clothes i think
they're trying to sell you a whopper
okay uh with all this uh wave function
collapse
it says the testing or man manipulation
of a physical system in order to yield a
numerical result
so they're going to manipulate a system
of some kind okay
physical system could be a table a chair
right
in order to yield a numerical result
they say this table measures one meter
okay but how do you measure something
you can't see
or touch does it make sense to go to the
lab
and measure that which you can't see or
touch
what are you measuring are you just
you know stretching your your measuring
tape across the
across space nothing is that what you're
doing you know what are you measuring
the length of nothing
this is the issue and so the predictions
that quantum physics makes
are in general probabilistic
yeah they're probabilistic because uh
they're going to be doing math they're
not going to be doing science they're
not going to be doing physics
okay they're not going to have an
explanation for you what they're going
to be doing is
measuring speed energy mass
charge you're going to measure
parameters
okay and that's what they're going to
call science
when it's all what what is it really
it's mathematical physics meaning
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics at all
physics is explanation math is
description what these people are going
to do
is give you a description and
the explanation that they're going to
give you is just going to blow your mind
and here's the first one okay
what's the first explanation to give for
the wave function collapse well here you
see it
from these two fellows primarily from
heisenberg the guy on the right
lower right um it's a copenhagen
interpretation and that's the most
popular still
today after uh almost 100 years
of quantum mechanics an irreversible
process causes the decay of quantum
coherence
okay which imparts the classical
behavior
of what observation or measurement they
call those
uh those are classical behaviors if you
can measure something you're doing
something classically
okay that's called a measurement but if
you're doing something
in this world that you can't see prove
or measure or whatever well then we're
they're going to call it
a quantum process
so we have the difference between on the
one hand a classical process which you
can measure
and these that you cannot measure and
that means get a numerical value that
you can rely upon
why because we're going to see that it's
kind of fuzzy it's a fuzzy because
you're
measuring according to them right
measuring a wave
okay and a wave is kind of stretched out
it occupies
lots of space in fact all the way to the
edge of space time and occupies the
whole universe
they call it a field they have all these
words for it
but as soon as you take the measurement
that the one you're going to put down
well it collapses the weight function
and it turns
into a ball okay and here let me show
you
a little pretty picture of that okay
here's uh what they're talking about
okay
here you have a uh a wave and it
suddenly
suddenly turns into what a ball
that's what they're saying that's what
they say when they say it's a wave
function collapse okay so
what they're saying is uh something
converts into something else in this
case they have this elongated
uh thing and as soon as you take the
measurement what happens well it
collapses to a ball
and that's just an example okay so the
question is
what is the process it turns out that
they don't explain the process
for a specific reason and the reason is
that
you know they cannot explain it they
cannot explain how that happens
and the other reason is that um they're
talking about math they're talking about
what you measure and they're talking
about equations
when they're talking about when when
they talk about a wave
function they're talking about math so
they're seeing the function
collapses forget about the adjectives in
front of it
wave quantum wave forget about this
adjective it's a function what do you
mean the
function collapses well again it's a
probabilistic
theory so it deals with probabilities
and so they're doing math and they use
these terms
which are of physics when you talk about
something collapsing
you're talking about something physical
you know
what collapses well you can say the
government collapses well yeah that's a
concept and that's using the word
collapse
in a in a with a concept with an
abstraction you see the government
collapsed okay or money collapse
but when you use it with physical
objects then it's very clear you say
well you know what collapse was the
building
that's a little different now you're
talking about things that has to do with
physics
the other stuff you know has to do with
either philosophy if you're
going to talk about reason uh purpose
let's talk about belief
uh opinion you know why you think the
thing collapsed
that's religion but we're going to do
physics we can't use the word collapse
and apply it to a concept an abstraction
such as
an equation a function what the hell
does that mean
but see they give you the notion that
the reason they can't measure
accurately the location of the particle
is because the wave function collapsed
they're suggesting that more than that
they're
actually telling you in your face
they're talking about something
physical they're saying there's this
thing called a wave
that's waving out there and then
suddenly it collapses to a ball
that's the notion they want to give you
but you know when you put them against
the wall they say well it was the blade
function and what we mean by that is the
function collapse to
a reading to another to a value
so they're talking about abstractions
but they're using these physical terms
they give you the impression that
they're talking about physics when
they're not they're talking about math
okay so that's extremely important to
understand in this situation
okay and unfortunately we have someone
on the internet and his name is
nick lucid and he runs a site
uh known as the crazy asylum the crazies
the uh what is it
the physics asylum the quantum asylum
whatever these
he's called today and that's nick lou
said he looks more or less like curly of
three stooges so i like to call him
curly and he says what is actually
waving you know he's talking about
again this wave function collapse he
says what is this wave that's waving
and he says probability he answers that
question
what is waving is probability what is
waving is a function
are we talking about physics are we
talking about math
how can you say that a function waves
i mean you see the problem we're talking
about abstractions
that are moving and that is very scary
okay
and you say anyway she continues says
remember we're taking a trip down to
quantum brick road
yeah we're headed to oz okay here
a whip is anything that has a back and
forth shape
now what kind of shape is a back and
forth
form shape whatever what is the outline
of a back and forth
you see how they use these words they
want to apply a word of physics such as
shape
and they want to apply it to what to
back and forth which is a verb
you can't have the shape of running what
is the shape of flying what is the shape
of swimming
that's what this guy is saying and they
use these words and they
it only confuses the dissertation
because you don't know what they're
talking about are they talking about
physics
are they talking about math and
abstraction what are they talking about
what is a wig
function collapse okay so yes
well wave is a verb he says it okay it
is also a noun
waves are things power waves
things the flag is a thing what it does
is wave you can't say that a wave is a
thing
but this is how these people talk and
it's um
you know uh pervaded the uh the language
completely
so this is how these people talk and and
it is very confusing uh especially to
the lay men
out there who's not careful uh or
tune into really what these people are
into or what they're saying okay they
say oh that's over my head that's nice
to know
science is so great and they walk away
and they never learned anything
because they talk these people talk this
way he continues says a
a mathematical function he defines it as
what a relation between
sets of numbers okay so it's a relation
there's a relation a concept that's what
a function is
a wave function is a function that looks
wavy
great wave function is wavy function
great
good good uh definition uh again these
people never
learn to define words that's the problem
quantum wave functions
are a bit more abstract than that more
abstract than that
okay i don't know i don't know how much
more abstract you can get than that
they're unobservable by definition okay
so here we have a wave function they say
there is something there it's called the
wave function
they're talking about a function which
he says is a verb right
or a wave that is a verb as well right
and and they're waving it okay but he
says because
i guess uh their concepts
they're unobservable yeah no kidding all
concepts are
unobservable so should we remove that
from science because they claim that
science is what you can observe
measure test in the lab and here they
can't even
touch it or observe it see it
is this outside the bounds of science
according to their own definitions by
the way i'm not
introducing my definition at this point
i'm using their own definition they're
not being consistent
with their definitions okay so the point
is the quantum wave function isn't even
completely
real he says that not me okay
it's not real uh i thought the physics
dealt
with what's what's real what exists
isn't that what physics is about what
exists
don't isn't that what we're interested
in understanding
uh what exists out there what causes
gravity what causes
electricity or magnetism what exists out
there that we can't
see or touch or prove through
observation
or go to the lab so that we can see or
touch it
this is not an issue where you go to the
lab and run an experiment you're not
going to figure this out to an
experiment you got to sit back
and visualize you say what could mother
nature be using there to produce all
these
effects that we can't see or touch we
can't hear
the mediators of these effects that's
what
that's what science is that's explaining
giving me an explanation how the
universe works
but to say that you're going to wave the
wave function and that a wave function
cannot be observed
yeah no kidding i have trouble always
observing uh
verbs usually i observe nouns okay
okay so uh he ends up his little
dissertation saying the following
instead of looking at the quantum wave
function itself
we look at its probability density
my god probability that's what they look
at
i hope you can see the probability
density in other words
these people are going to be doing math
so he says so what's a quantum wave
function
okay what is it it's a mathematical
entity
calls it an entity that has no physical
meaning
those is those are his ending words so
what did we learn well we learned that
there's no such thing as a wave function
it doesn't exist it's not an object it's
not a thing
but he calls it a thing he calls it an
entity okay
and what's more he's gonna wave it and
he says well because
it's not just a wave and that a wave is
not just an
object a wave is also
a noun a thing an object
so they're treating it that's where
that's why they use the word the term
mathematical physics because the physics
part is the object that they're going to
use
and you're not supposed to take it
literally and then
the math part is the description of you
know uh
the equation that describes its motion
and
that's the part they're interested in
they say well we're interested in this
and math uh
we want to do equations so that we know
how it moves
and some of that might have to do with
uh technology
none of any of that has anything to do
with physics
physics is understanding how mother
nature runs her shop
and what mediator she uses to do that
you gotta visualize the mechanism
for that you got to introduce objects
that you can't see
or touch because you're going to use
them to explain a mechanism to someone
else
what the theories what you have going
through your mind what you're
visualizing okay
and yeah you can put ghosts in there and
okay that's your explanation fine
uh someone might believe it other people
might not
okay and again whether they believe or
not outside the bounds of science
but yeah anyways here we have the second
version
of uh of this wave function collapse
it's known as the many worlds
interpretation
my god if you thought the other one was
crazy this one beats it by a mile
says there is only one wave function
okay
the superposition of the entire universe
so they're saying there's only a single
wave function they're visualizing this
as a field i guess that extends
throughout space and time space time
okay so what is this field well
everywhere it's got all these vibrations
what are those vibrations
they're the waves it's a single wave but
it's everywhere
okay and whenever you
pinpoint one you know you're going to
measure you're measuring only a piece of
this monster
this web that extends throughout the
universe
that's the notion they want to give you
the wave function never collapses
according to these people this it's
constantly there
it doesn't collapse so there is no
measurement problem
so these guys are uh people who believe
in the many worlds they
they do not subscribe to the traditional
copenhagen interpretation which is you
know the wave
function collapses these guys say no
there is no wave con
function collapse or measurement problem
what happens is you have this
monster which is a bunch of waves that
form the field
and whenever you measure you're just
measuring it locally
okay but what happens uh
it gets even worse because it says all
possible
outcomes of quantum measurements are
physically realized in
some world or universe you know i talked
about
schrodinger's cat just briefly let me
illustrate it here here it is okay
i presented this the other day a couple
of times already
that's schrodinger's uh cat there and uh
you know
for those of you who don't know the
story you put the cat in a box
and you have this
what is this poison you can say it's
it's some radioactive poison
that's in a glass jar and
what happens you break the glass with a
hammer that's timed and at some point
you know the
glass breaks and the radiation come out
comes out
and supposedly it kills the cat now you
don't know if the cat is already dead in
there
if that's already taken place or not all
you know is that
the cat is either alive or dead because
you haven't opened the box
now you open the box and uh they say the
quantum
mathematicians say the cat collapses to
one of two states either he's dead or
he's alive
that's essentially what they're doing
with particles okay so this is an
analogy for the particle universe of uh
quantum mechanics
okay what is the issue well the issue
with um
the multiverse uh theory in other words
uh
this uh many worlds it's it's uh trying
to incorporate
general relativity the notion that there
are many worlds out there many universes
and what happens is the cat
actually uh lives in all these universes
he he branches out in all of them and in
one universe
uh he's dead and another one he's alive
and another one he's standing up and
another one he's maybe
half dead half alive because he's maybe
sleeping waking up
you know so so the cat for every step he
takes in his life
he branches off into these many universe
and many worlds
now what sense can any of that make is
is this a rational explanation
these people study 10 years at the
university and this is what they come up
with
they come up with the wave function
collapse
the uh wave collapsing to a ball
we don't know what the process is but it
does so and the other guys say no no it
doesn't really collapse it
you know the the wave or the particle or
whatever that branches off into all
these universes
and here it collapses here it didn't
collapse who knows what happened
but they say the wave function doesn't
collapse because it covers the entire
universe
you figure it out what they're talking
about yeah in fact i wonder if they know
what they're talking about
okay uh there's a couple more and i'll
go quickly through these they're not so
popular
and this one comes from the broglie and
bone theory these two
guys essentially and a lot like them
einstein among them they were all wave
theorists
and they're a little different than
people like born
like born like bore and heisenberg who
were
more particle theorists they believed
more in the particle
and so it was really a fight between the
particle theorists and the wave
theorists and the particle theorists one
one on the day and eventually they kind
of merged it into this notion of field
they came up with a
field theory of quantum mechanics and
they like that because it kind of unites
general relativity which is a field
theory together with quantum
and that's what they're trying to do
today somehow figure out how the
equations
uh from one discipline general
relativity can match uh the ones from
quantum mechanics you're trying to get
an equation that explains both sides
okay
that's essentially what strength theory
is trying to do but it says there is no
actual collapse these people don't
believe in the collapse either okay
system description contains the weight
function and also the position of the
particle
this is kind of strange because you know
wave is motion
position is something static they say uh
who was it mr heisenberg said you cannot
have
both motion and position the amount of
motion or
the you can't zero in how much motion
there is
um if you know the position and vice
versa if you know the
uh motion you do not know the position
of the particle
and i always like to say it synthesize
it by saying you know when the ball
moves it doesn't stand still
and when it stands still it doesn't move
that's what the uncertainty principle
essentially says
and so here we seem to have a
contradiction because
uh this guy is talking about uh as well
as anyone who's a wave theorist in
general within quantum
okay they they uh try to fix this
problem saying look uh
there's a difference between the wave
and the position
and these people are saying we can have
both we can have our cake and eat it too
okay
that's essentially what these people are
saying because they're saying there is
no collapse
okay and therefore there is no
measurement problem also like these all
the i said
role of the wave function is to generate
the velocity field
for the particle okay
and velocities are such that the
probability distribution
for the particle remains consistent with
the predictions of
orthodox quantum mechanics if people are
talking about probabilities they're
talking about predictions they're
talking about descriptions they're not
going to explain
anything to you even with this so-called
theory
it's not a theory it's a description
theories are not just
uh descriptions and descriptions are not
theories a theory is an explanation
these people had to turn their theory
their descriptions into theories why
because they had to somehow make sure
that everybody out there understood that
mathematics is a synonym of science
mathematics is a synonym of physics
why because physics is how the world
works and they claim
hey mathematics can give us a clue or
tell us exactly
how the universe works that's
that's their notion their
line of reasoning for how science works
how physics works and
of course how math fits into all this
stuff
okay okay uh interaction with the
environment during a measurement
procedure
separates the wave packets in
configuration space
which is where apparent wave function
collapse comes from
what interaction i say what is
interacting
so far they have no physical object how
can it interact
all they have is functions how can a
function interact with anything
how can a wave interact how can he bang
against something
they don't have physical things they
don't do
physics with things okay and that's the
first uh
rule of physics you need to have a thing
okay without a thing you have nothing
okay that's the way i like to look at it
okay and uh one more which was this
this is another interpretation okay it's
the objective collapse model
uh not necessary to go in any detail
through this because what they're saying
is they modify schrodinger's equation
that's math it's got nothing to do with
physics then they say
they're talking about the behavior at
the microscopic
level okay and again they're saying um
quantum obviously that is a measuring
close to the that given by the
schrodinger equation
again they're talking about numbers
functions
equations they're not about descriptions
they're not going to give you an
explanation for
what this objective collapse model which
is a
theory according to them with theory you
haven't explained anything
all you did is describe it's like saying
i measured the table okay
so how much does it measure but it
measures uh one foot
it's a small table okay and uh what have
you explained
is that science because you measured a
table and you give a
perfectly accurate reading what the hell
is that
again it says for microscopic objects
the nonlinear modification becomes
important and induces
the collapse of the wave function again
collapse of the wave function it's
collapsing the function they're trying
to
tell you that they're doing physics that
they're working with something real some
real object out there when uh good old
nick
told us just now that there is no such
monster
okay and you know what is the mechanism
how does the
wave function collapse please explain to
me put it on the board show us
a movie of how the wave function
collapses i want to see it
i want to see it keep your mouth shut i
just want to see the movie that way i
can see how it collapsed
what are they gonna put a function a
bunch of a's and b's x y's and z's
the main difference of objective
collapse models compared to the other
approaches
is that they make falsifiable
predictions
that differ from standard quantum
mechanics yeah falsifiable prediction
what is that falsifying is an opinion
for you god is false for this other
fellow
god is truth who's right who falsified
who
falsification is an opinion nothing more
than an opinion
and they're falsifying predictions
that's even worse because
if you falsify a mechanism you can say
well let's go to the
lab and find out but these guys are
talking about predictions
what are they talking about uh where
where uh the
scorpio is gonna be in the sky someday
uh you know
the sun or or the moon are they talking
about
uh astrology is is that what this is all
about
what are my conclusions
uh quantum measurement has to do with
detecting the
invisible and intangible can they detect
the invisible and intangible
no of course not so there's no purpose
in running any experiment in the lab
because you're not going to be able to
touch or see
what you're looking for you got to
define it and say oh this is what this
is what it is
now you know what you're looking for you
say i lost my wedding ring
okay what are you looking for well i
know what a reading uh wedding ring is
you know you look for a ring you're
looking at
some little hole there right so you know
what you're looking for but when these
people say you know they're looking for
something that is intangible invisible
please draw it so i know
that i found it when i when i see it
you know i mean how are you going to get
how are you going to
deal with something that's intangible
invisible except through
visualization through imagining it
and drawing what's in your brain for
someone else so that they can see the
same thing you
saw okay okay there are no observers in
science
but quantum is saying that the
mathematicians
okay can't see or detect
the invisible mediators so
there does observation play a role in
science if it does
then we have to eliminate quantum
because in quantum they tell you right
up front that they can't observe
whatever they're studying in the lab
so is observation part of science or not
and then uh
the mathematicians insist in spite of
this right
uh in doing experiments to see and
detect them
to see and detect what can't be seen or
detected
you know and when you put them against
the wall they say well
they continue to provide physical
interpretations despite
some merity dismissing all physical
interpretations
as philosophy
so you figure out is that philosophy is
telling me
why a pen falls to the floor is that
philosophy
or the mechanism right or is that
physics
and these people dismiss physical
interpretations as philosophy
then they give you a physical
interpretation the most idiotic the most
irrational one they can find
they tell you they cannot observe or see
see or detect it in any way
and then they say come with me to the
lab so you can see the experiment that
i'm going to run
to what the see and detect the unseeable
undetectable so you figure it out if
this uh
quantum measurement is even a problem
uh should we even pay any attention to
quantum measurement
does it have anything at all to do with
physics
let's go with the questions people asked
when you get them up here
here's the first one
i get it in there okay here it is a
fellow ass or says
it says quantum computing is far more
capable we
dealt with quantum computing last time
okay is far more capable than
conventional computers
of solving equations we have yet we have
not yet solved okay
or we have yet to solve whatever you
wanted to say there
yeah it's fast and so it calculates
things we've never been able to
calculate so
is that science we have an equation
that's science
what is uh an equation a description
that's how it is
so is is that what science is just doing
an equation and
uh having computers develop more
sophisticated equations
or solving them or being faster at
solving them
is that it because it's really only a
question of speed it's a question of
speed because
um they say that even a
normal computer can solve these
equations it might take a hundred
thousand years
but it'll solve the equation and so now
it's it's ultimately only a question of
speed that's all that quantum
so-called computers uh bias
and so if it's a question of speed what
does that have to do with science
it might have to do something with
technology certainly it's got nothing to
do with science
especially if science is what
explanation they're not explaining
anything with this
okay with quantum computers okay
fella says i think it was the same
fellow yeah uh
says um matt that i say that mathematics
isn't a part of science or physics yeah
correctly
we don't use math in science we don't
use math and physics
for that you have to do one thing first
and that is define what science is
you have to define what physics is and
here we define it
okay and what is science science is
rational
explanations okay that's what science is
and we can defend that uh definition
if you have a different definition no
problem but then you have to defend it
you can't just state something and say
well that's what we all believe in
we don't care what you believe in you
know we care what you can defend that's
what
enters the realm of science okay so uh
keep that in mind okay the next issue he
says
knowledge hasn't been defined that i'm
saying that knowledge hasn't been
defined correct
correct again number two and here it is
uh this is what knowledge is let's put
it here
uh knowledge today is essentially a
variation of what uh
plato said which was justified through
belief
knowledge is a synonym of belief
okay that's what knowledge is when you
know something it's because
you believe it that's what you
know because you believe it so you know
that god exists
because you believe that god exists and
the other guy
knows that god doesn't exist because he
believes that god doesn't exist
that's why knowledge has no place in
science
okay epistemology is the study of nature
origin and scope of knowledge
epistemic justification and the
rationality of belief
okay again what is the study of
epistemology
it's the study of belief okay
and epistemology aims to answer the
following questions and here you can see
why
epistemology meaning knowledge has to do
with belief
these are the types of questions it
tries to answer what do we know
in other words what do we believe what
does it mean to say that we know
something what does it mean to say that
we believe something
what makes justified beliefs justified
what makes beliefs
yeah it's all about beliefs and how do
we know what we know in other words how
do we believe what we believe
that's all the person said so yeah
knowledge has nothing to do with science
even though the word science derives on
the word knowledge
it was mistaken by the people who
derived it from there
and second knowledge is just belief so
we don't deal with knowledge in science
or with belief
okay and then the last one says throw
out
scientific method that i'm throwing out
the scientific method meaning really the
mathematics method the method of
mathematics
and uh here it is here's uh the method
of mathematics for all of you
okay what does it have it has all these
elements
it starts by gawking you have to gawk in
met
in a mathematical method you observe
something with your
drooling mouth wide open it's important
to have that mouth wide open to be
drooling okay
otherwise you're not observing you gawk
again you have to repeat the observation
otherwise it's not part of the method
okay then you make a
you you prophecy you you make a prophecy
you can you
make a prediction okay uh because
prophecy making predictions is part of
uh
of the mathematical method they they
underline it they underscore it they
they say it's a very important
part of the mathematical method which is
observation
and prediction then here you test your
hunch with an experiment
and we just heard that quantum mechanics
cannot do experiments on things that it
cannot see
see or touch so i don't know how they're
going to test their hunch
okay by doing an experiment but that's
what they do
and they measure they calculate they do
some math you know they come up with
some kind of
equation equation okay which with which
they
describe an invisible mechanism and
they're going to call that
a theory they're going to call that
description a theory
they propose the most ridiculous
physical interpretation you can imagine
it's got to be ridiculous otherwise it
doesn't enter the world
of mathematics okay you got to have a
ridiculous and irrational
explanation otherwise you're going to be
frowned upon they're going to say what
do you think you are you think you know
you think you know how this universe
really runs
so you know it's got to be ridiculous
then they'll believe you
then you've got to sell it to
high-placed individuals and ask them to
give you a medal okay that's important
and there you see them uh at the bottom
of
the saiyans and they hold hands you know
and you have to
all hold hands and believe in the same
thing okay
and then once you get your medal well
you gotta censor and treat uh
as cranks and crackpots those who are
skeptical of your theory
so if you have an irrational theory and
you're okay and if someone is skeptical
of that
theory you call them a crank and
uh you put your thumb on him like an ant
okay that's the way it works in
mathematics how does it work
in real science well here it is
i think this is it uh
here it is and it goes like this you
have the scientific method
what is science rational explanations
right right and uh
these are the steps okay and the steps
are
hypothesis in other words the
assumptions you present the assumptions
so that people can follow your
explanation that's what we're going to
be doing here explanation explaining
and you present the objects because
you're explaining you're going to
explain a mechanism
you're going to have your definitions
okay hopefully they're
they don't rely on synonyms meaning
they're not circular
definitions and then you're going to
present the first few frames the initial
scene essentially of
what you're going to be explaining what
you're going to build your theory theory
upon okay and then you explain
an explanation what do you explain
you're going to explain a mechanism or
a cause we're talking about physics
again so
this is what you explain and then you
reach your
conclusions you know your uh physical
interpretations your personal
interpretations of uh of
how this thing could have happened and
your uh give your conclusions okay
essentially
that's what it comes down to and uh you
know you have your corollaries
so on so that is
what we call the scientific method okay
okay and um think i had one more here
give me a second
a couple more in fact here's the first
one
if i take a pen and troll it uh
clockwise okay i didn't understand what
to see
clockwise the other end is twirling
counter clockwise yeah correctly you
take a pen
or pencil in this case and if i twirl it
see if i can fit i'll get my wand i
think you can see this better maybe
okay and i'll twist it around so if i
turn it
uh what is that counterclockwise you
should see
it going clockwise okay hope you can see
that
i can't and then uh here i'm turning it
in the opposite direction i'm turning it
uh clockwise yours should go
counterclockwise
so you can do that with a rope you can
do that with any elongated
object you want you can do it with a
steel beam okay
then you can use anything that's
elongated so he says so this works
on other objects besides robes yeah
correctly but not
on other objects just any other objects
you know i could turn this this little
flat
wafer which i used to simulate the
flat earthers okay and i could turn this
one
also you know uh counterclockwise your
end should go clockwise
okay but it's got to be it's got to be a
single
entity it's not very elongated but
whatever you have in your hands that
you're twirling
the other guy's got to look at from the
other end so that they're both united so
that they both to get go together
okay the problem with quantum is they
have particles
they have two particles okay here's let
me see if we can remove this for a
second they have two particles okay and
here's one here's the other one
okay and if this one turns
clock counterclockwise in my case
clockwise in your case
does this one move why would that one
move
unless they're connected so they have to
be connected
that's the issue and that's where the
rope model comes in because with
connection you can explain a lot of
phenomena
uh without connection without some
binding without
some interconnectivity well then you
cannot explain very much
because you cannot explain how one moves
and the other one
is influenced by it without having some
kind of connection
that's the issue so that's the critical
point
and that's where the rope came in okay
and here's a
another comment question
a person says he says let's suppose
there is an electromagnetic rope
perpendicular to spin
of magnetic thread okay then magnetic
thread will collide with the
electromagnetic rope
or not uh we don't know what you mean by
collide
meaning touch when you define
touch maybe we can answer your question
what do you mean by touch
and you can't use the so don't look it
up in the dictionary because you can't
use
uh the words of ordinary speech there
they're very easily destroyed so if you
want to use it just you're just going to
waste your time
now you have to come up with a
definition of the word touch then we'll
know whether the thread can touch the
rope or the rope and touch the thread
okay and whether they can collide
meaning touch
okay so you got to define the word touch
we don't know what touch means
please define it scientifically and then
we can
follow your train of thought and answer
your question
okay so that's uh a little homework for
you
okay and final issue it's got to do with
this fellow
nick lucid someone asked a question
uh in fact asked a series of questions
to nick lucid
he came here and posted them i went to
that to nick lucid's site to find out
uh what he had said yeah and this is
what he said he says
and event horizon is the skin of this
black ball
and nick lucid answers kind of
yeah a very definite answer okay
kind of is it a solid black ball
no it's just a region of space that's
what a black hole is
just a region of space so it's not a
black ball it doesn't have size it's not
a thing it's not
not an object what it is is a region of
space what is space
nothing so we have a region of nothing
and that's what a black hole is
and he says do black holes crush matter
out of existence
when you have some phds out there that
stated uh
you know directly and i've already
covered that in the past and he said we
don't know
because we can't receive anything from
inside the event horizon
so those are your definite statements
from nick lucid of physicists or
so-called physicist a mathematical
physicist
and these are the people who run the
show and these are the people who censor
everybody else
okay okay with that i'll see you next
time which will be on
sunday we'll see